hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control ac.l
2-3.1.15 bet you never guessed that from
the description of the video authorize
remote execution of privilege commands
and remote access to security relevant
information
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who is feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
deep fars and nist SP 10171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news the
best news
bigly good news you found your home here
at on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
get into it so in cmfc control ac.l
2-3.1.15 authorize remote execution of
privilege commands and remote access to
security relevant information it is
mandated that virtually anything related
to a privileged account or command in
this case a command example installing a
piece of software that requires
administrator permissions to install is
actually authorized documented permitted
and logged this specific control
emphasizes the remote nature of that
execution as generally speaking most
serious attacks happen remotely so let's
jump into specifically what it is that
they're going to assess you on and the
kind of answers they're looking for
so four major assessment points on this
one first we're going to determine if
privileged commands authorized for
remote execution are identified so have
you identified them somehow now a couple
ways you can do it you can obviously do
in a written policy another thing is
there's probably some group policy that
you can Implement to Define them or
another option is you could say yes that
they've been identified in the seam
solution right because your seam
Solutions can identify uh what all is
being executed as well so lots of places
you can identify this now assessment
Point number two determine if security
relevant information authorized to be
accessed remotely is identified uh so
again we say yes
determined by file system excuse me
permissions ACLS and system access
capabilities uh so again yes the answer
is it is identified and these are the
ways that we identify them assessment
Point number three determine if the
execution of the identified privilege
commands via remote access is authorized
uh-oh getting a little more specific
here so what authorizes it well Group
Policy uh so if I was given a sample
answer Group Policy prohibits the
execution of privileged commands via
remote access for non-privileged users
right because you have a group policy
saying probably that only admins can
install software things like that the
same solution then logs all privilege
commands executions which are authorized
so again your seam solution you're going
to be able to hit the authorization that
way too
um and again that's not actually how
they're authorized but you certainly log
that they were authorized when they
executed and things like that assessment
Point number four determine if access to
the identified security relevant
information via remote access is
authorized uh so again sample answer
here is only those users who are
authorized to access security relevant
information and authorize for remote
access May perform this function so
again you probably have to give a
demonstration of that with your system
to show them that a standard user just
simply can't log in and do those
activities now uh if you're looking for
help with this I have good news for you
all right and on call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff just dropped in their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day all
right we teach you how to level up and
be a proper on-call compliance hero for
your company eliminating gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
right that's what we love those higher
profit margins I know what you're
thinking right now you're like but Mike
it's government work margins are low and
you know what I'm thinking I'm thinking
you're silly you hire us because I will
teach you how to change your life now
that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you at least
my team will looking for more help
getting compliant our compliance experts
are always on call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get to help
you get compliant right now yes links
that will help you right now some kind
of links maybe they're malicious but
you've got something to protect yourself
don't you I'm just kidding I'd never put
a malicious Link in here anyway if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you or all of my incredibly awesome
YouTube gaffs help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash the Subscribe button
because there's super cool super secret
stuff that we release all the time and
it's not really all that secret because
if you're subscribed then you know it
but if you're not subscribed it'll be a
secret until you search YouTube for my
beautiful shining face or just help with
cmmc which is what we do until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]